Hello! Welcome to Michael's Business Top Tips.
This month, we're looking at successful networking.
Now, business networking is an essential skill...
...to find new customers, to build new relationships,...
...find new partners, and to grow your business.
How can you do successful networking?
Here are four steps to help you.
First, use the Internet.
Many business people now use sites like Facebook or Twitter,...
...and other social media to build new business relationships.
I'd recommend especially this one, www.linkedin.com.
This one is especially focused on business professionals,...
...who want to network online...
...and it has over 75 million members globally.
Second, seek networking opportunities.
Every business trip, exhibition, conference, training seminar,...
...these are all wonderful opportunities to build new business networks.
Don't be shy, go up and speak to people you don't know.
Remember to smile, make eye contact,...
...and use a confident handshake to make a good first impression.
Third, discover common interests.
Don't just talk about business.
Also, try and find out what they're like as a person.
For example, sports or hobbies, or interests, or hometown, travel experiences.
This builds a much closer relationship.
Fourth and finally, follow up.
It's very important once you've met somebody, contact them sooner after.
I'd recommend emails on the next day.
Say how nice it was to meet them and express hope to see them again soon in the future.
Remember, you never know who will be the next big customer for your business.
Thank you and good luck.